Speaker 1: Let's go next to John from California.
John, you're on the air.
Hi, David, can you hear me?
I can hear you fine.
It sounds like it sounds like there's birds
where you are.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I'm actually outside on the
front porch.
Speaker 1: Is it like a titmouse or some kind
of parrot?
What is that?
Speaker 5: No idea, it's in the distance,
so I'm not really sure.
No problem.
What's going on out here?
So I had a.
Speaker 1: And we just lost you, it sounds
like you were about to say you have a.
And then I'm guessing the board was question,
but then we just we lost you completely.
Are you still there?
Speaker 5: Or I was wondering, so even if
we can, even if there is a divide wouldn't,
even when if the Republicans still end up
voting for whoever the Republican primary
is anyway?
Because, you know, you said it still benefits
Democrats in a way, but I think when eventually
they would eventually just go Republican because
they want to vote Republican.
OK, so
Speaker 1: John, would we?
We lost the first half of the question, but
I believe I know what it is, which is even
if there is a Republican civil war for now,
are Republican voters eventually just going
to vote for whoever is the nominee?
Is that was that roughly your question?
Yep, that's correct.
OK.
I think they generally will.
So like, for example, right now you've got
anti-Trump Republicans, formerly Trump Republicans
and Trump Republicans all battling they're
battling over.
Was it an insurrection on Jan. six?
They're battling over.
Should we censure people like Liz Cheney and
Kinzinger?
OK, fine.
Eventually.
Aren't they all going to vote for the nominee?
The answer is they mostly will.
But when the left isn't really bringing anything
super inspirational to the table, what we
have to hope is that some of those Republicans
will just be disgusted that their wing lost
and they'll stay home.
I don't think it's likely many of these Republicans
would vote for a Democrat in 2024.
But if the Republican Party continues the
infighting, hopefully some of the Republican
voters will just get sick of the whole thing
and opt to stay home.
Speaker 5: Okay, that makes a lot of sense.
Okay, because, yeah, okay, that makes a lot
of sense.
Thank you, David.
And I just have just two quick questions.
I know it's just a quick answer that you'll
have please both of them.
One is to the second or the first.
One is, do you think they're?
I know you're not a virologist or do you think
this a possible another variant that's out
right now that we don't know of?
Because I know you said it takes time to to
for us to figure out one.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So this is not my opinion.
I mean, it's what what virologists say is
there absolutely are variants out right now
that we don't yet know about.
That's just the way it works.
The question is, do any of them become concerning?
And we just don't have an answer to that yet.
Speaker 5: Okay, thank you.
And the second one is, have you ever thought
about contacting Discord, about notification
disruption during calls?
Because I know it's annoying.
I know it's annoying for you.
Speaker 1: I think Discord would say we have
we have features to turn that off and just
explain to people how to do it, you know,
I don't know.
Discord is going to do anything special for
me.
Speaker 5: OK.
Very sad.
All right.
Speaker 1: Thanks, John.
Appreciate the call, John from California
dropping some serious knowledge on us.
OK, we're going to take a very quick break,
but we're not ending calls.
OK, so if you would like to speak to me, just
hang on because I'm going right back to the
phones in a moment